oh go on my name is feel bad
welcome back to amnesia jarred [ __ ] whoa
that's not good for anyone
alright so that's a picture of maybe the
bro no it's not the bro I don't think it
is the bro I recorded the parent shut up
not gonna help anyone
alright so video with my webkinz
microphone and I didn't realize I'm
sorry but it should be sounding a lot
better now I'd really I know 99%
probably don't care that much about
sound quality but it really kills me I'm
like Oh am I so stupid right barrel did
you [ __ ] up my shot quality it's not how
it is woah [ __ ] vibrates and [ __ ] man
Carl is that really tall I wonder if
they glue them together or just put them
yeah let's not go there
I don't really trust these statues I'm
not gonna [ __ ] oh no is he gonna [ __ ] my
life no no you [ __ ] opener
I just just don't do it man
um too fat for this anyway goddamnit I
had so many [ __ ] hot pockets I'm too
fat why are you doing that to me
is he gonna come or what ha ha do you
know what I'm gonna go behind you
problem son i canna fall for your tricks
anyone else for that matter why are you
now whatever
see how much I care why you're looking
fat what are they doing here what is
alright
focus on the target pity alright I trust
you it could be hiding inside of him
that would have been a good scare
alright so are we looking for something
here I think we're just trying to escape
at this point actually oh yeah bro cut
peered no you can't direct that's the
third cave in this week and this time
one of the servants was crushed by the
rubble damn thing wasn't even able to
make it nice man no matter there is a
replay what is actually proving to be a
problem is that I am more of a more
often finding my Road through the
mansion blocked by Kevin pants net as a
result I determine a formula alright so
we need to explode the recording alright
come on we need to make explosives
alright aqua regia and calamine in that
container check
then we need to poisons Glan wish i got
and then we need to heat it up and mix
it up in a machine and then pull the
[ __ ] lever and then we got some
explosive [ __ ] look at me spin beauty
that's amazing look at their shirt Cobra
oh sorry
breath is that your hands in a bucket I
always wanted my hands to be in a bucket
oh that's feeling James let's go I kill
him for you Billy don't worry about it
now let's get this explosive
I'll let me sleep on the hammer first
all right whatever you say Stephano so
is there anything in here oh we got the
machinery here
and it's in your box but we don't have
to have a container no we don't we could
use this poo bucket and as hands in it
come out here and see we can use this
design alright so far now let's find a
way to get out of here since we're now
you're telling me on this building oh
all right Jonathan Byrd's wife let's
check over here just to be sure I don't
forget anything
so this is where I came from yeah ah
Jason Christ video [ __ ] kill you what
I'd be the same breath
don't kill I slice happy hour boss a lot
my boss okay it was or does the math for
you what the [ __ ] does that even mean
okay I don't have ribbon in here
all right you go first Ivana I don't
well Jennifer what the [ __ ] I love your
beauty I came all the way all right
Jennifer it's cool it's cool
I like that I appreciate your
persistence Jennifer but it's not
happening wave the [ __ ] is that coming
from
hi it's fine I'll put you down there I
hide him give me the morphine ah [ __ ]
visitor mindzoom penumbra wow that's
rude ass dude he almost saw me that was
close I
than a closet I've made no sense that
fun but if we got morphing and we got a
job we give it the water fin
Raja jaja jaja by the [ __ ] I buy we need
that correct me out lion not today yeah
it's all your fault definite oh you tell
your penis that way all right so that's
what I'm gonna explode okay I get it
cool I would never find this way again
okay all right sorry I'm here he's
coming
I'm a bunny good for you I'm about a
beauty I know I can see that what did
you do to your face
I try to put lipstick bunnies aren't
supposed to wear lipstick you know all
right bunny oh I didn't his name Snoop
Dogg see you know Chuck I found it all
right
Snoop Doggy seemed really cool but
Bonnie and me Oh Jenna max is there
anything else inside here bunny that you
want to tell me about nothing no it's
just me and up dad we like to get high
in here all right dad cool I guess
good for you check out my hat beauty all
right I did it
are you happy all right those balls it's
Jennifer standard for naked all right
good good good so this room is actually
kind of pointless [ __ ] waste of time
we need to find the [ __ ] something
become that sounds great
whoa this room is actually kind of cool
whoa whoa they're like shaking and stuff
cut I would hump that look at that
that's awesome keep shaking breasts are
you shaking fire patty good
oh this is a bull this is the bowl Oh a
container
now we just need to come down to better
go back to the thing bully
is there something inside you
I love the bull alright good for you man
so there's actually nothing else here
alright well we got a lot of things
today I am feel like nothing can stop me
absolute meander can we jump down there
cuz maybe there's something there I
don't know can we put you in directly no
okay
Sneed find a condo Adam come and then
would be good if it wasn't here I guess
it's in the poop bucket no all right
step dogs
see you later ah no that is not [ __ ] we
just gotta look for it again
Oh what the hell are you nearly a little
panic
you made me fight them off again what it
had stopped spinning alright where they
do it in check this place out I need to
find the cam what is this
pretty matter yeah this is it this
correct no it's not oh would you never
went in here did with me
all right left better I know that it's
kind of creepy alright I don't know why
that's did alright this is it has to be
in water
huh
Oh what the hell
father can you go and check if it's safe
I'd pay they all did for ya
got nothing come back - I just gotta be
in here Donny you can't come back now
I'm sure here every time eventually god
damn act alright it's gotta be pissed
when he comes back how - for sure
alright let's go back and find the thing
that chemical room no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no we were so good together
but then you flew away with your crime
mescaline thing yeah what the [ __ ] does
he know how to teleport now come on come
on come on come on come on come on
Jesus where's the lab Eric very sorry
priority are you all right
okay let me just remember so I can
remember my way back it's not in here is
it that's some vagina
all right running out of ideas here
oh laboratory I found it found found it
looks like a need why don't I have the
poison gland why is it not in my
possession I picked it up in the last
episode son of a [ __ ] like a flower I
guess you are technically a flower what
do I start with I don't know what Wally
why the [ __ ] did he okay I need that
thing that spins there you are
let's put you there no you are an idiot
I know man just chillax all right let's
make some cake together nope nope maybe
it's not here after all we'll see in one
second it is here all right start the
back all right
now you have to add the aqua column at
all right I'm doing it man and then the
Kalin I actually broke em
all right and now we put the poison glad
how does Madan
extractor I guess this is this thing oh
come now close that [ __ ] and then put
that up that there pull the lever
I did it oh my gosh pity I'm jumped oh
happy right now
look at this luck it as I'm sliding all
right I'm so proud a minute
I'm quote backflip that's how proud I am
that's how happy I am
go pin it and make me proud I love you
Bailey
we will be together one of these days
and scissor you remember it good I don't
[Music]
okay now that's the vagina let's explode
it and then it's episode with a boom oh
I know what you were thinking pared it
if you exploit me don't do it why
shouldn't I do it
where the [ __ ] is he where the [ __ ]
not every right my god I don't know
penny but you would burn ah what [ __ ] I
think something bugged
no Magga started oh thank god pretty
penny
haha you are stuck you and I'd be they
don't do it if you kill me don't you get
it
the world will end with barrels dying
why are you going the wrong way
haha I diverted your pity so you would
go all right whatever barrel it doesn't
matter what you say you're going down
with me
son of a [ __ ] baby you know what pity
we can be friends you know you and I are
not that different after all you
remember
Perry do you remember that custom story
abduction I was when I was actually
talking to the brow but to Bro us I was
actually trying to divert you so you
could you escape I'm actually on the art
side really barely not done I am your
friend you know what I don't believe
your lies for one second alright but why
can i [ __ ] put it there
son of a [ __ ] what but my my what am I
supposed to use it on I thought uh huh
uh-huh uh-huh well I think I may be our
hey dude what this makes no sense
I'll maybe over here no it doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense and it showed up a
text didn't it okay okay
man oh I'm gonna kill that son of a
[ __ ] ha ha I should buy panic
you're alive for that oh you killed one
of my friends doesn't matter you will
die in the end anyway Bailey I use the
son of a barrel all right I will add in
surface earlier but I crave you enjoyed
subscribe to come Bridgette now I'll see
you next episode whatever I make babies